Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Arrow episode 10 video.
They did all the things there are now 3 versions
of the black canary.
So let's break it down.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet.
People are gonna be reacting to this for a
while.
They were a couple big twist in the episode
but the biggest was probably like the last
couple minutes when they reveal who is going
to be the new black canary on the TV show
they didn't say outright but they heavily
implied so I'll try to explain everything
and there is a new round of the injustice
giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video It's for
a copy of the game.
Man they really packed it in the like the
last couple minutes of that episode like they
want you to know that there's so much stuff
coming in the back half of the season Stephen
Amell was teasing stuff on twitter so try
to include some of that in the video to sol
let's do top 12 instead of top 10, number
12, just picking up in the last moments of
the midseason finale where he sees a Laurel
in the arrow cave is just like what the hell
you doing here.
And she tries to explain that he's very reluctant
there was this big thing in the episode where
Oliver has this policy of trust but verify
Felicity was kind of doing the same thing
from her and of things in most of us had a
pretty good idea of what was going on.
Liquid seen the promos.
We had a lot of theories about which version
of Laurel.
It was based on what the producers of set
the rules that they've created for themselves.
There aren't a lot of rules in the comic book
world, but arrow has like a couple set rules
for itself in one is no more resurrections
which was a nice joke in the episode number
11 is the crackpot explanation that she gives
to Oliver and he's very skeptical because
he's like I was there I saw everybody you
were nowhere to be found like he had a vision
of her, but it was just sort of like head
Cannon Laurel was like his mind speaking to
himself through his subconscious, so she says
that after all that Sara went back and pulled
her out of time she asked Sara to drop her
off here my favorite reaction that Felicity
had in that moment because she's just to be
like only got to miracle this is wonderful.
But then she's like wait a minute.
Isn't it a coincidence that you arrive just
after Oliver's found out that he's murdered
my boyfriend and after the dominators did
this big assault on the planet to we had a
team up for.
So even if you had no idea that this is black
siren like already there.
Like big warning lights going off in the background.
But then number 10 Oliver goes to meet Diggle
and we learn what the plans are going to be
for the back half of the season one Diggle
is gonna try and get out the legal way which
is where the district attorney comes in and
Oliver is continuing to track down the woman
quota quote.
The woman that which is not the end of the
episode the train him and Prometheus back
in Russia.
So that's Talley all cool so that's gonna
be a big part of the back half of the season
so the Tina some hard-core stuff in the flashbacks,
but because of all the Prometheus stuff that's
happening in present day that means that will
also see Talley in present day of eventually
number nine was the brought but boss that
has it out for Oliver he's the guy that's
working with Kovar in a sort of like a corrupt
a more corrupt version of one of his brought
from brothers.
So it's sort of like honor amongst thieves
their kind of like the rogues, they have a
code of honor, but this person is like way
worse than that he's working with Kovar and
is trying to turn Oliver in a reverse version
of what Oliver is trying to do with black
siren in present-day so that kind of teased
you off as to what was going to be happening
with black siren a little bit, because Oliver
wasn't going to change it.
Even though you wonder about black siren.
It seems like she's not going to change either
there's a whole bunch of black siren that
we have to talk about number eight was the
actual black siren reveal that was so funny
were she's working on the DNA ragman comes
in and asks her and makes a joke about you
know what about an evil twin and then the
lightbulb and Felicity's head just dings on
and she's like no we actually have those there
from earth two she walks and starts using
her sonic cry, but then gets away.
So number seven they start watching all the
footage they learn how she got out of the
pipeline prison.
We get the the Backstory, so she's been locked
up in the pipeline prison at star labs on
the flash for the past year.
So ever since she gets start at the end of
season two Prometheus got that information,
knowing that Laurel is a weak point for Oliver
in the rest of team arrow they may or may
not address it on the flash sometimes things
will happen on arrow that they'll only address
in minor ways in the flash and vice versa.
So I guess we'll just have to pay attention
next week and find out because that will be
pretty messed up.
If nobody mentions anything about black siren
this big person that they had to face last
year, just totally broke out and didn't set
any warning bells off number six is the DA
working Diggle's case it seem like they were
setting him up to try and take down the general
himself like he's this hard-core person they
haven't made the reveal about his character
yet.
So I feel like I want to say it but just in
case you guys don't know who the character
secretly is on the show but I feel like most
of you know who he is but it made it sound
like he was going to try and eventually killed
the general they might be team that up for
later in the season, but the district attorney
storyline independent of Diggle is gonna be
big in the back half of the season there still
some big reveals for his character number
five they catch black siren Oliver still wants
to believe there's good in her Felicity isn't
having it.
She mostly turns out to be right in the episode,
but Oliver still believe there's like a little
something in there down deep, so he's trying
to everything he can to Turner but they have
this really funny conversation where she talks
a little bit about her version of Oliver that
died 10 years ago they make it sound like
they completely reversed positions.
So maybe he's the one that died in the life
raft or he just went down and drowned his
father's the one to became the green arrow
on that earth after that she moved to Central
city, to try and make a new start for herself
ran into the zoom and started down the dark
path became the black siren that you see today
see you could argue that she was good before
Oliver died once he died that sort of like
broke her heart and set her down the dark
path, so that all goes in to what happens
to her at the end of the episode, but number
three a funny moment that she has with Felicity
was so great images of knocking her out later.
So Felicity gets the upper hand which he just
starts taunting Felicity what happened between
you things don't look so hot you have a sister
I hear he likes that it's totally true.
So she's not lying, but she just trying to
get a rise out of Felicity so that she can
escape they eventually recapture her in it
seems like they really want to drag her through
the mud like she tries to kill Felicity even
though Oliver's like there must be some good
in you, and it seems that she's gone completely
to the dark side the reason I think they did
that and then had Oliver say you don't maybe
there's something still inside of her somata
keep her close and Argus so that she can come
back next season and potentially have some
black canary versus black siren episode or
they can make her good if they want to in
the future it's really then just putting her
on the shelf.
Rather than saying she's always going to be
bad or she's always going to be good.
It just gives them a couple different options
for directions to take the character down
the road because they are confirmed for season
six.
I think will get a season seven as well, but
I think the other reason for keeping her evil
black siren in not trying to turn her into
metahuman Black Canary and put her back on
the team.
It just so that Katie Cassidy has a different
character to play in the way that rip hunter
is a different character.
The season Tom Cavanagh plays a different
character every season is just something more
interesting for the actors to play especially
if she's not gonna be a series regular.
So number two is the Talley all cool reveal,
so she's been a train Oliver during Russia
will see that, during the flashbacks then
shall get involved with the Prometheus plot
in present-day because for some reason she
train Prometheus the same way she trained
Oliver, so will have to learn about that relationship
and what he was like when he came to her what
kind of thing she talked to Oliver and if
you're wondering about Nissa shall probably
come back on the show eventually they could
totally do a Talia versus Nissa episode with
the actors that plays Nissa is on a different
TV show so she's not as available, it's kind
of like the new Bennett Stephen Amell was
like the new please come back and play when
people were like who do you want to come back
everybody wants deathstroke to come back and
be deathstroke the new Bennett is a series
regular on a couple of the TV shows.
So just really hard for him to do that but
the number one is the brand-new black canary.
So if you didn't understand what was happening
at the end of the episode in the bar when
she sonic scream those dudes out the windows.
That's the actress that's going to pick up
the mantle of black canary of eventually whatever's
can happen they'll explain in the next episode
next week how long that's gonna take whether
or not shall end up wearing Laurel's old jacket
or shall have some different costume the name
of the casting description only reads Tina
Boland it's not a name from the comics so
they could be one of those things where they
change it down the line or it's a fake name,
but either way, this is the actress who is
going to be fighting with team Arrow as a
new vigilante and the black canary of eventually
you may have also noticed that she's from
hub city.
A lot of you asked that they keep teasing
hub city does that mean that they're going
to do the question mark Guggenheim said they
really want to do the question that I don't
know if they'll fit them in this season or
fiddle be a season six thing is like right
of the top of the list of new comic book characters
that they want to do just address black canary
drama that I saw going on during the episode,
I know some you were complaining about this
because it is a change from the comics and
a lot of he wanted Laurel to be the black
canary on team Arrow.
But just remember they have two black canary's
on the TV show now because one stashed away
and Argus please have a lot of options going
into next season, but obviously the back half
of the season is gonna be grand with a whole
bunch of Talia new black canary and doubling
down on Prometheus stuff, so is gonna get
really crazy really fast, but if you like
was a pretty great episode I like the action
I love Katie Cassidy coming back to guest
star.
I don't know how many more episode she's going
to be in, but because she's an Argus she might
come back at the very end of the season to
help them with their Prometheus problem because
he'll definitely be around for the rest of
the season what's can happen next is the just
made some big announcements about the flash
movie or some avengers Spider-Man behind-the-scenes
stuff for infinity war that I want to post
and marvel is supposed to have some crazy
big announcement the doing in the morning
if it turns out to be something really cool,
then I'll do a video for those will be the
next couple of videos congratulations to the
new flash ring giveaway winner Mr. Jolly Green.
Please private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post a DC video.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the trailer for the next episode
of the flash and you can click here for my
flash episode thank you so much watching everybody
high five I'll see you guys tonight!